Bonjour à tous ! Aujourd'hui, on va parler de ce qui,
pour certains biologistes,
est l'équivalent du big bang pour les physiciens,
Un court moment de l'histoire de la Terre où la vie animale s'est mise à foisonner.
On appelle ça l'explosion cambrienne.
Cette période on la connaît notamment
grâce à des fossiles incroyables
découverts au Canada et qui pourraient faire
furieusement penser à un film de science-fiction,
les fossiles des schistes de Burgess.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Commençons par un petit rappel chronologique.
La Terre, tout comme le système solaire d'ailleurs,
s'est formée il y a environ 4,5 milliards d'années.
Et étonnamment, il semble que la vie
soit apparue assez rapidement
Puisque les plus anciennes traces de vie dont on
dispose datent d'il y a environ 3,7 milliards d'années,
c'est-à-dire "seulement" 800 millions d'années
après la formation de la Terre.
Les premières formes de vie étaient des organismes
très simples, des unicellulaires,
c'est-à-dire constitués d'une seule cellule
comme par exemple des bactéries.
Plusieurs fois au cours de l'histoire de la vie,
sont apparus des organismes pluricellulaires.
Mais pendant longtemps, ils sont restés
assez rudimentaires sur le plan anatomique.
Au bout de 3 milliards d'années d'évolution,
les organismes pluricellulaires
les plus complexes qu'on pouvait trouver
pouvaient être comparés, en gros,
à des méduses ou à des éponges.
On dit de ces organismes qu'ils ont une symétrie
radiaire, c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont une surface extérieure,
mais l'organisation interne reste assez basique.
Et puis soudainement, il y a 542 millions d'années,
on a vu apparaître toutes sortes d'animaux très différents
avec une symétrie qu'on appelle bilatérale.
Ça veut dire qu'ils ont un devant, un derrière, un haut et un bas,
c'était une grosse révolution anatomique.
Et surtout, une structure interne bien plus sophistiquée
que les précédents organismes,
avec des organes, un tube digestif, des carapaces,
un système nerveux et même des yeux !
Et toute cette complexité d'organisation
est apparue soudainement,
enfin, soudainement à l'échelle géologique,
c'est-à-dire en à peu près 20 millions d'années.
C'est ça qu'on a appelé l'explosion cambrienne !
Les bestioles typiques de cette époque, ce sont les trilobites,
vous pouvez en voir un fossile ici,
on en a retrouvé des milliers comme ça.
D'ailleurs, leur apparition soudaine
dans les couches géologiques,
qui marque le début de ce qu'on appelle l'ère
cambrienne, posait un sacré problème à Darwin.
Comment expliquer avec la théorie de l'évolution
qu'en si peu de temps, tant de
complexité animale soit apparue ?
La compréhension qu'on a maintenant de cette période
est très liée à un site en particulier :
Les schistes de Burgess.
Il s'agit d'une carrière située dans
les montagnes rocheuses canadiennes,
dans l'état (N.D.E :  pas état mais province) de la Colombie Britannique.
Ce site avait été découvert au 19ème siècle,
et on y avait trouvé quelques fossiles qui ressemblaient
à des crevettes mais enfin, sans plus ...
Sauf qu'en 1909 le paléontologue, Charles Walcott,
décida d'aller le visiter pendant ses vacances,
et il réalisa qu'il s'agissait en fait d'un site exceptionnel.
Déjà parce qu'on trouvait un très grand nombre de fossiles,
mais surtout, ces fossiles avaient un niveau de détails incroyable,
et c'était lié au fait qu'ils avaient
conservés la forme des tissus mous.
Il faut bien voir que ce genre de situation
est extrêmement rare.
Généralement, les animaux sont enfouis lentement par sédimentation
et comme les tissus mous se dégradent rapidement,
les fossiles ne conservent en général que les images
des parties les plus dures des animaux.
Mais dans le cas de Burgess, on pense qu'une coulée
de boue ou un événement violent de ce genre là
a enseveli très rapidement les animaux
et a permis de conserver aussi la forme de leurs tissus mous.
Walcott a ensuite consacré les 15 dernières années
de sa vie à fouiller les schistes de Burgess
et il en a ramené plus de 65 000 fossiles.
Alors il faut bien voir que quand un paléontologue ramène
des fossiles, ce n'est pas juste pour les collectionner.
L'idée c'est de les analyser et de les classer
pour essayer de se faire une idée
d'à quoi ressemblait la faune de l'époque
et comment elle se positionne par rapport
à celle qu'on connait aujourd'hui.
A l'époque de Walcott, on divisait le règne animal
en 7 grands embranchements :
les éponges, les coraux, les annélides
c'est-à-dire, en gros, les vers,
les arthropodes, les mollusques,
les échinodermes dans lesquels
on retrouve les étoiles de mer
et les chordés au sein duquel on retrouve
notamment les vertébrés donc Nous !
Et puis en dessous de l'embranchement on avait des groupes,
notamment les arthropodes qui se divisaient en 4 groupes :
les uniramés, les trilobites, les crustacés et les chélicérates.
Et qu'a fait Walcott avec ses 65 000 fossiles ?
Et bien, il les a patiemment analysés,
il a essayé de faire des reconstructions
de l'image en 3 dimensions des animaux
pour les classer dans les cases correspondantes.
Vous vous souvenez par exemple des fossiles de crevettes,
il les a appelés Anomalocaris, ça veut dire crevette anormale,
et il les a logiquement classés dans les crustacés.
Les choses auraient pu en rester là,
mais 50 ans plus tard, dans les années 60 et 70,
3 paléontologues ont décidé de réanalyser
tous les fossiles trouvés par Walcott.
Et là, ils ont eu de sacrées surprises !
♪ [Générique] ♪
En analysant les fossiles disponibles et en essayant
de reconstituer de quels animaux il provenaient,
trois paléontologues de Cambridge,
Whittington, Briggs et Conway Morris
se sont rendus compte qu'il y avait plein de trucs qui ne
collaient pas dans les classements qu'avait faits Walcott.
Et ils ont fini par comprendre que ce qu'ils avaient
sous les yeux était des animaux
complément différents de ce qu'on connaissait jusqu'alors.
Des animaux nouveaux pour lesquels
les cases existantes ne convenaient pas.
Pour reclasser les fossiles des schistes de Burgess,
ils ont dû créer plus d'une dizaine de nouveaux
embranchements, alors qu'il n'y en avait que 7 à l'époque,
et une bonne vingtaine de nouveaux groupes
d'arthropodes, alors qu'il n'y en avait que 4.
Et ils se sont rendus compte que Walcott,
en voulant faire rentrer les fossiles
au chausse pied dans les cases existantes
avait complètement raté le fait qu'il avait sous les yeux
quelque chose de totalement inédit.
Les fossiles de Burgess montrent
que la faune qui existait à cette époque,
non seulement s'était développée incroyablement rapidement,
mais en plus elle était beaucoup plus diversifiée
que ce qu'on s'imaginait avant :
il y a vraiment eu une explosion de la vie animale à cette époque !
On va voir ensemble quelques exemples
de ces animaux fabuleux
qu'on pouvait croiser dans les eaux à cette période.
Alors, à chaque fois on va regarder des fossiles,
et on va regarder des reconstruction en 3D
qui ont été faites à partir de ces fossiles.
Alors il s'agit évidemment d'une interprétation
un peu artistique mais rigoureuse.
Alors voici par exemple Opabinia, c'est un petit animal
de 5 à 10 cm qui savait nager.
Il se nourrissait vraisemblablement
avec cette drôle de trompe en forme d'aspirateur
qui lui permettait probablement d'attraper sa nourriture.
Sur sa tête on peut compter 5 yeux,
même s'il s'agissait évidemment d'organes
bien plus rudimentaires que nos yeux actuels.
...
Vous en connaissez beaucoup vous,
des animaux qui ressemblent à ça ?
La première fois que les paléontologues
ont présenté en conférence scientifique
un dessin reconstituant cet animal, l'audience a rigolé.
Allez, autre exemple, Hallucigenia,
un animal qui porte bien son nom.
C'est une bestiole qui marchait au fond de l'eau
et qui avait des épines pointues sur une face
et des tentacules sur l'autre.
Alors pendant longtemps, les spécialistes ont débattus
pour savoir où se trouvait le devant du derrière
et même pour distinguer son haut de son bas.
On a pensé initialement qu'elle marchait
sur les épines avec les tentacules sur le dos
avant qu'on finisse par se convaincre du contraire.
Un des animaux les plus fascinants
qu'on ait retrouvé à Burgess
c'est Anomalocaris, vous vous souvenez,
la crevette anormale.
Et bien Walcott s'était vraiment bien planté.
En fait ces crevettes n'étaient pas des crevettes,
mais étaient des parties incomplètes
d'un animal bien plus grand
qu'on a réussi à reconstituer par la suite,
mais seulement dans les années 80.
Vous le voyez ici.
C'était un monstre des mers ... de 60 cm.
Alors ça ne fait peut être pas énorme, mais
je ne sais pas si j'aurais aimé en croiser un, hein !
C'était probablement le plus gros prédateur de l'époque.
On pense qu'il mangeait des trilobites.
...
Un autre exemple, Wiwaxia.
Un truc rampant qui avait à la fois des écailles et des épines,
et dont on ne sait pas très bien
s'il s'apparente plus aux vers ou aux mollusques.
Allez, pour finir, un animal qui ne paye pas de mine, Pikaia.
Il ressemble à un espèce de ver aplati sur les côtés
et Walcott l'avait logiquement classé dans les vers.
Mais non, en fait il appartient à l’embranchent des chordés,
vous savez, l'embranchement qui contient les vertébrés,
c'est-à-dire qui nous contient nous aussi.
Alors on n'a évidement aucun moyen d'affirmer
avec certitude que Pikaia est notre ancêtre,
mais il est vraisemblable qu'à l'époque,
l'ancêtre de tous les vertébrés actuels
ressemblait à peu près à ça.
♪ [Générique] ♪
J’espère vous avoir convaincu
qu'à l'époque des schistes de Burgess
régnait un incroyable foisonnement de la vie,
une fascinante diversité,
comme si soudainement la nature avait décidé
d'expérimenter comme une folle plein de nouveautés.
Vous savez, on parle souvent de l'arbre de la vie
pour exprimer la diversité du vivant.
Et bien, à cette époque la vie animale n'était
pas vraiment un arbre, c'était plutôt une pelouse,
c'est-à-dire que des tas d'anatomies différentes
ont été expérimentées par l'évolution
et il semble que seules quelques-unes aient finalement
donné les animaux qu'on connaît à l'heure actuelle.
Et tout ça, on le sait grâce aux incroyables
fossiles des Schistes de Burgess.
Alors rassurez-vous, depuis on en a trouvé d'autres
un peu partout dans le monde
et notamment au Groenland, en Australie et en Chine.
Mais qu'est-ce qui a pu déclencher
cette incroyable période d'innovation.
Et bien, on ne le sait pas vraiment.
Une première hypothèse, c'est que l'apparition d’oxygène
dans l'atmosphère et donc dans l'océan
a facilité le développement de tout un tas d'animaux nouveaux.
Il faut bien réaliser qu'à l'origine,
il n'y avait pas d'oxygène sur Terre
et que c'est la photosynthèse réalisée par certaines bactéries
qui a permis son accumulation dans l'atmosphère.
Mais comment le taux d'oxygène
a exactement varié à cette période,
la question est encore débattue.
Autre hypothèse, une origine génétique.
Il est possible qu'à cette époque soit apparue
une bonne combinaison de gènes
dont les mutations aient permis aux animaux
d'expérimenter assez rapidement
tout un tas de nouvelles formes d'organisations anatomiques.
Dernier groupe d’hypothèses, une perturbation soudaine
dans l'équilibre écologique qui régnait à l’époque.
Ça peut être une perturbation externe, bien sûr,
mais aussi un déséquilibre interne,
par exemple, il est possible que l'apparition des yeux
ait augmenté fortement les capacités de prédation
et ait donc exercé une pression
de sélection nouvelle sur les animaux
et mené au développement d’innovations
comme la nage ou bien les carapaces.
Quoi qu'il en soit, à l'heure actuelle,
on n'a pas d'explication définitive
et l'explosion cambrienne garde ses mystères.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, je vous recommande
le livre "La vie est belle" de Stephen Jay Gould
que j'ai pas mal utilisé pour cette vidéo.
Gardez quand même en tête que le livre
a maintenant une trentaine d'années
et qu'un certain nombre des choses qu'on y trouve
sont assez remises en question aujourd'hui,
notamment la manière dont on classe les fossiles aujourd'hui
se fait selon une nouvelle méthode
dont je n'ai pas parlé qui s'appelle la cladistique
et qui mène à des résultats légèrement différents
et j'en dit un mot dans le billet qui accompagne cette vidéo.
Un petit mot pour finir, il n'aurait pas
été possible de faire une telle vidéo
sans les belles illustrations qui l'accompagnent,
donc je voudrais sincèrement remercier,
d'un côté le Royal Ontario Museum
qui m'a fourni un certain nombre de photos de fossiles
et ces très belles animations 3D
des animaux des schistes de Burgess.
Je voudrais également remercier
Nobushi Tamura qui est illustrateur
qui m'a laissé utiliser certaines de ses images.
Vous pouvez aller visiter son site et notamment,
un grand nombre de ses images
sont en licence Creative Commons
donc merci à lui pour cette initiative.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo.
Si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la liker et à la partager.
Vous pouvez bien sûr vous abonner à la chaîne
pour ne rien rater des futures vidéos
ou bien découvrir les précédentes.
Vous pouvez retrouver les actualités de la chaîne sur Facebook et sur Twitter
et vous pouvez également me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Merci, à bientôt.